game against Prague and actually game
three the game before this one ferrugia
was completely winning we were saying
he'd established complete domination
Pratt could barely move and then
ferricia just swapped Queens off at the
wrong time and lost an end game so it's
clear where fruition needs to do his
work
um I mean this is kind of a it's been a
myth for a long time that ferrugia in
the end game that's his big weakness but
it seems to be what has cost him today
at least so he has to check out your
ground like your Grandmaster of course
maybe among other things yeah remember
everyone a course a chessable course by
David Howell the Olympic gold medalist
and the world number one Magnus Carlsen
is available on chessable it's actually
on sale as well well there's a big
discount right now if you check out that
course to basically learn to grind like
a Grandmaster alireza refers he did try
but after 55 moves in game four it is a
draw and Prague takes all three points
in this match